R all right thank you um so the the
title of this Workshop is like online
and matching based Market design and I
guess in English and can be ambiguous
you know is it's like the union or the
intersection but I was gratified to see
that many of the talks didn't have an
online component and so I feel less
guilty about giving a talk that doesn't
have a stable matching
component all right slides are no longer
appearing
I have my own cable if we think this is
a cable
issue okay um and this is Joint work
with a bunch of students George and
Raman stepen and and Stephen is an
undergrad applying for PhD program so
look for him in your pod oh
no here I've got this other cable maybe
that one
will more
friendly
okay so I want to think about a basic
question which is um you know when is it
a good idea for a a decision maker who
wants to maximize their utility to act
as if predictions about the future are
correct and when should they do
something more complicated in
strategizing and to formalize that
here's a you know simple model I've got
a decision maker that's got some set of
actions and the other thing that's
relevant to their utility is some state
which I'll think about representing as a
vector this could be something exogenous
or it could be um
some um aggregation of what what other
players have done so this could be a
utility function in a in a
game um and so these States they're
vectors I'm going to assume that this
utility function is linear and lipshits
in the state and just to sort of say a
couple words about
that it's Yeah you sort of worry I say
oh linear this might be like a really
limited setting um it's actually quite
General so for example your utility
function could be arbitrary and the
state could just tell you uh in each
coordinate what your payoff is for
playing each of your actions that would
be linear uh you could have
some there could be sort of some D
distinct outcomes that will be realized
in the future you don't know what they
are maybe the the state is the
probability ility distribution over
those outcomes your expected utility is
Linear by linearity of
expectation uh we'll talk a little bit
about routing games maybe you know we've
got um you know a road Network and
there's going to be some traffic on each
Road and you're going to pick a path and
your utility you know you care about
your commute time your utility is the
sum of the congestions on the roads
that's linear could be an online added
matching on the on the plane in case uh
this was like important it could be an
online max weight matching problem right
maybe the state tells you what is the
weight of the edges um you know the the
weight of a matching is the sum of those
things that's linear um there are ways
to represent extensive form games in
this way we'll talk about that a little
bit so so um this is all to say this is
a pretty General setup you shouldn't be
scared of the word linear
here okay so what should you do well if
you if you knew what the state of the
world is if you knew what this Vector s
was it's clear what you should do you
should best respond you should choose
the action that maximizes your utility
given the state of the
world the difficulty that I want to
think about is is the fact that you've
gotta act before the state is known
right somehow we need to like predict
the state and and use that to act so for
example um I typed into Google Maps um I
asked it for uh traffic report in
Philadelphia not now but next Monday
okay so this is
a projection into the future of what
Google thinks the traffic will look like
uh on Monday right it's it's not correct
necessarily it's a
prediction um is it a good idea for me
to like plan my route out now as if this
is the traffic or should I spend a long
time studying the kinds of prediction
algorithms Google's using and hope to
come up with a more clever strategy as a
function of of this information I've
been okay so let me tell you about
calibration maybe the way you've if
you've heard about calibration before
the way you've heard about it is
probably you know predicting like binary
outcomes like you can talk about weather
forecasters and whether they're
calibrated so the traditional story is a
weather forecaster says something like
there's a 20% chance of rain tomorrow
and the way you want to check if he's
calibrated is you look at all of the
days for which he's predicted a 20%
chance of rain and you verify that it's
rained on 20% of those
days but you can talk about calibration
when you're predicting a real valued
Vector instead of just a binary outcome
what's the more general
definition it's just that the forecasts
should be statistically
unbiased not just marginally but
conditional on the forecast itself okay
so conditional on predicting a 20%
chance of rain the probability of rain
should be 20% but more generally could
say conditional on predicting some
Vector of Road congestions in the city
of Philadelphia the expected value of
those Road congestions should be that
big Vector that's a bigger ask but in
principle you could Define this
thing and it's of a classical idea is
that it is a good idea to follow
calibrated forecasts if forecasts are
calibrated you should follow them okay
what does that mean how do you formalize
that
well you know maybe you've got some
extra information that the forecaster
doesn't have the statement I'm about to
tell you doesn't apply in that case okay
this is about if the only information
you have is what the forecaster is
telling you and so the kind of act the
kind of object you are coming up with
when you're deciding how to act is a
policy which Maps predictions to actions
okay there's a lot of such policies you
could try to come up with sort of
complicated ones that exploit problems
in the system but but something that if
this was a longer talk I would prove for
you it's only four lines that follows
almost directly from the definition is
that if the forecasts are calibrated
then it is a dominant strategy amongst
all policies to treat the forecasts as
correct and to best respond to them to
act straightforwardly to just best
respond to the predictions as if they
were correct this follows from
calibration and the fact that your
utility function is linear in the
stage Okay so so that's great
calibration has some good news but it's
also got some bad news so okay the good
news calibrated predictions incentivize
agents in a very strong sense to um
treat them as correct they can be used
straightforwardly and transparently you
don't have to try to like game the
system and the other piece of good news
is is that it's actually feasible to
come up with uh calibrated forecasts at
least in principle we've known since
Foster and Bora that there are
algorithms that can interact act in a
sort of online sequential environment
and and come up with forecasts that are
guaranteed to be calibrated in hindsight
even if the sequence is chosen
adversarially so you don't need the
sequence to have any nice properties At
All by the way I I talked about
calibration by writing down like an
expectation what does an expectation
even mean if there's no distribution
what calibrated in hindsight means is
that the expectation is over a random
choice of day if I pick a yeah you you
play out everything now there's an
empirical distribution over the time
steps the distributions pick a random
time
step okay but there's some bad news too
um two pieces of bad news really so
calibrated forecasts are not necessarily
useful even constant predictors could be
calibrated if they happen to predict the
mean outcome okay so this sort of
statement I made to you about it being a
dominant strategy to like Faithfully
follow a calibrated forecast you know
it's like a little bit sneaky which is
that if I'm making complicated forecasts
the set of policies mapping forecast to
actions is complicated and this is a
strong statement but one way to sort of
you know game this statement is to make
very simple forecasts always forecast
the same thing and then the set of
policies mapping forecasts to actions
it's just the constant set of policies
and it's not a not a super you know
useful
thing
um and you know like actually making
these sort of constant
forecasts that doesn't really make sense
in an online setting like that would
make sense in a distributional setting
but like for a constant forecast to be
calibrated you need to predict the mean
and you don't know what the mean is
there is no well-defined mean in an
online setting and so you know like
maybe if you think calibration is too
easy actually bad news um that both the
statistical and uh computational
complexity of maintaining d-dimensional
forcasts grows exponentially with d so
this means you know the running time
grows exponentially with D and your if
you measure your distance from
calibration that'll you know go to zero
eventually but at a rate that is
exponentially slow in the dimension so
calibrating
yeah so calibration is something that is
feasible in a one-dimensional binary
setting and makes sense to Define in a
high dimensional setting but is not
really feasible in a high yeah so if I'm
a basian decision maker and I have a
prior about traffic in
Philadelphia for I never want to be
calibrated I want to shrink the signal
towards my
PR your posterior belief will always be
calibrated if if your model is well
specified but I'm not talking about um
distributional
settings um okay so you know like so
what do we do so in high dimensional
settings I want to ask is there
something short of calibration we can
ask for uh that still makes it a good
idea in some sense for agents to treat
the forecasts as correct and you know
can we obtain it efficiently like we
want these good properties but we want
um even in even in adversarial settings
for us to be able to you know have both
running time that is polinomial and the
relevant parameters of the problem and
Bounds that go to zero at this
polinomial rate and uh does thinking
about this question lead us to new
learning algorithms new learning
algorithms say in games with large
action spaces that seems like sort of a
specific question to ask so I might have
reverse engineered this
slide okay so what's the online
prediction setting oh was the context
Space
X um so every day you might learn some
features relevant to the prediction task
right if I'm a weather forecaster maybe
I get like some meteorological
observations other
stuff and there's some
um convex prediction uh space so maybe
you know if there's like d outcom I'm
forecasting um my the the kinds of
things I can predict are probability
distributions over those D outcomes
that's convex maybe if I'm predicting
traffic on road Network in Philadelphia
um you know okay maybe I can just you
know maybe it's like just a rectangle
maybe I can predict any traffic on any
road or maybe I even want it to obey
flow constraints those are convex
sets um and then what's going to happen
is in
rounds the learner is going to first
observe the context whatever features
are relevant to the prediction
task then the learner produces some
prediction congestion on the road
Network a probability distribution of
outcomes and then the learner finally
gets to observe the outcome eventually I
see you know what is the weather I get
to measure the roads congestions but
like only after the decisions have been
made okay
and so okay so that's the setting and
um let me tell you a thing that you
might ask for in this setting that won't
it won't be immediately clear why this
is a good thing to ask for but it's you
know some like basic computational
primitive you can ask for and it'll turn
out to be
useful so let's say that an event is
just some like function that Maps maybe
the features that are available at some
time step T and and the prediction that
I make at time step T to like to like an
indicator zero or one is today you is
the event active today or not as a
function of what I predicted and what
else I knew that day and it could be
more complicated if you wanted but
that's not important for this
talk and so maybe what I could want to
do is given some collection of events I
might want
to promise that my forecasts are
unbiased they have no statistical bias
which means that if I sum up over my
forecasts that should average out to
what I would get if I summed up over the
outcome I don't have to get it right day
by day but I I should get it right on
average and maybe I don't want that to
be the case just marginally asking for
that really to be the case just on
average that would be you know too easy
maybe I want it to be the case
conditional on each of these events so
if I sum up just over the subsequences
defined by when these events are active
I should also want it to be the case
that the sum of my predictions averages
out to the sum of the
outcomes so calibration is a special
case of this you can instantiate this
condition as calibration if my events
correspond to the indicator that I have
made each of the possible different
predictions I want to be unbiased
conditional on the predictions I've made
but the problem with calibration is
there's you know exp you indeed
Dimensions there's exponentially many
predictions I can make and therefore
exponentially many conditioning
events okay um so like why is
calibration hard is in D Dimensions is
it because there's exponentially many
predictions I can make the my action
space is exponentially large or is it
only because the number of constraints I
need to satisfy is exponentially large
right so suppose I ask for D dimensional
predictions there's still two to the D
of them
but I only want them to be unbiased
subject to like a polinomial number of
conditioning events now is the problem
easy can I solve that in polinomial
time and
um oh this in Reverse Direction can I
solve that in polinomial time and is
that good for anything like you know
what did I want to do with these
predictions like you know are there if I
can do this in polinomial time are there
polom polom sized collection of events
that are the ones that are relevant for
your Downstream decision task maybe you
only cared about polom many of the
events so let me talk about online
combinatorial optimization which is GNA
capture you know this little generalize
this sort of driving through
Philadelphia thing it's also you know
like an you could phrase online max
weight matching in this
way suppose I've got some collection of
dbas actions okay so in the in the
driving through Philadelphia example the
base actions are like the roads in this
network the edges in the graph if I
write down the network is a
graph now I've got some feasible set of
actions which are you know each action
is a subset of these base
actions okay so like maybe I'm gonna
pick a path from my home to my office
that is a subset of the edges not every
subset of edges forms a path I'm only
allowed to play
paths and what's the state um well the
state tells me something that I care
about um for each Edge okay so maybe
it's just the you know commute time
along that edge how long it's going to
take me to drive but I could have other
preferences as well maybe I have
preferences for you know non-all roads
or or roads that drive by the water or
you know maybe I like traffic who knows
okay so I have there's some gain or loss
if you like that um acres to each
Edge and
the relevant thing here is that the
utility for an action like a path it's
going to it's going to be linearly
separable across the base actions it's
the sum of my gains or losses along
these edges okay so this is the linear
aspect of
it okay so it's this game or you know so
far it's just the decision problem it's
got a lot of actions two to the D
actions potentially like there could be
a lot of paths in a graph but it's got
this lower dimensional d dimensional
linear structure okay so there's you
know I might hope to be able to uh
predict like what are the congestions in
on the
roads okay and if you if you sort
of have heard of you know no regret
algorithms in their simplest form expert
learning this also generalizes that
where your actions are just identically
the base
actions
yeah just trying to distinguish the
model from the example
oh so um yes okay but
like I want to
okay oh sorry yeah this s is not the
same as this s
uh what's an action so so in the example
of online shortest paths an action is
like a path in the graph from some
source to some destination that happens
to be a path is a set of edges more
generally in the general problem there's
some base actions those are you know the
analogs of the road and your real
actions can be collections of subsets of
those that's why there's potentially two
to the D many of them and I'm I'm not
imposing at the moment any
structure what those subsets look like
so so far we just looking the beginning
of your talk in which which is in the
state everything's going to be linear in
the state the whole time
so online shortest paths um you also
online max weight matching maybe every
day I it doesn't have to be a bipartite
graph actually right like maybe every
day the thing I do is pick a a matching
in this graph it's a subset of edges
that satisfy the matching constraints
and what I care about is the sum of the
edgeways okay so
um suppose I've got um a collection of
let's call them now subsequence
indicator functions but they look a
whole lot like these events I was
talking about okay that now rather than
as a function of the predictions as a
function of external context and the
action you play right now you're acting
in the game tell you if today's round is
part of a subsequence that I care about
or
not so I can talk about subsequence
regret which means that if I look at the
cumulative utility that I obtained
not overall but on the rounds for which
this subsequence was active that should
be at least as large as the utility I
would have gotten had I consistently
played the best fixed action on that
subsequence but I might have a
collection a big collection of such
events and I want this to hold
simultaneously across all of them even
though each day can belong to multiple
subsequence and it should be
Max um depending on whether you're
trying to maximize your utility minimize
your
cost um so let's define some maybe
interesting events let's say your
utility function is you and I'm going to
Define an event for each of the base
actions for each of like the road net
for each of the roads in the
network it is the event that when you
best respond to um my
predictions the road that you take
includes a partic path that you take
includes a particular Road okay so if
there's D edges in this graph I've just
defined D such events I can aggregate
all of the events that correspond to
your utility function that's V
events and maybe there's other you know
these subsequences I care about maybe I
care about you know like having low
commute time not just on average but
like you know after the you on days
after a a Phillies game when it's
raining and I decide to take a toll
road
yeah is the event a function of what the
actions or the event can be a function
of external context like if it's raining
and also the um prediction and if you
are best responding to my predictions
therefore the action that you
take so theem um for any collection of
events that you care about um if the CS
that I make happen to have low bias on
the cartisian product of these events
that you care about like say in the
routing game um together with these
events defined by your utility function
that your best response to my forecasts
chooses to take each of these
roads then you'll actually have a low
subsequence regret in hindsight in this
game so this requires you know if you
had a polinomial number of events like
only polinomial number of subsequences
you cared about only a small number of
only a polinomial number of um
conditioning
events and we can ask for this
simultaneously um for many different
agents okay it's not just for one
utility function I could ask for it to
hold simultaneously for M players with M
utility
function okay so for example uh what can
I what could I do with that if I could
make these low bias
predictions I could publish a single set
of traffic reports that are a good idea
to follow in this no regret sense um
simultaneously for a whole bunch of
agents who might correspond to different
Source destination pairs in this graph
who might have different utility
functions in terms of what their
disutility for traffic is how much they
care about tolls everything
else and they'd have no regret not just
overall but on rainy days on Mondays on
national holidays on days when the best
drought involves i76 or whatever Pol
collection of events you
about one other
application
um I canish forecasts um
suppose I'm in a setting where you know
there's only polom many actions maybe
and maybe also the type space is only
polom
large okay then I can sort of calibrate
in this way with polom many events to
all of the actions and all of the types
simultaneously
so for example uh first price auctions
are kind of like this right your type is
like a one-dimensional value it's also
your bid space and so I could publish
forecasts oh and you know like normally
how would you bid in the first price
auction like you might need to like have
some you know Common prior if you wanted
to play a B Nash equilibrium but where
do you get that from so I can publish
forecasts of um you know like what the
Distribution on the highest bid other
than your own was going to be and I
don't need to know what your valuation
is I can promise no matter what your
valuation is if you best respond to
these forecasts you'll have no swap
regret not just overall but also
conditional on properties of the item
like user demographics of an ad
impression also conditional on the
history of bids like the day after
you've been out bid or any other
polinomial collection of events that
that you care about as a function of the
history the context and your own action
okay um I'm out of time so you know you
can represent extensive form games as
special cases of online com tutorial
optimization I won't tell you but you
know it's kind of neat this gives you
new learning algorithms for uh extensive
form games which are another setting
with large action
space um
and you know like this would have been
kind of like disappointing if I told you
all of these things you could do with
these predictions but then you couldn't
make these predictions so I I won't tell
you how you make these predictions but
let me show you the theorem uh you can
do it so for any set of for any
polinomial collection of events um
there is an online prediction algorithm
that can make these d-dimensional
forecasts um even in an adversarial
setting okay the state can be
adversarially chosen so that your worst
case bias with respect to these events
is you know grows at most with root T
and at most with the log of the number
of events so information theoretically
you can have a ton of events the running
time is is polinomial in the number of
events so you unless you have a fast
computer you don't want that many of
them
okay so calibration great incentivizes
Downstream agents to treat predictions
as correct but it's got this terrible
computational
complexity um but the complexity does
not come from the fact that the action
space is enormous it comes from the fact
that it requires satisfying
exponentially many
constraints and if you only have polom
many events you want to be unbiased with
respect to you can solve this problem
efficiently
and for many Downstream problems I only
told you some of them the paper has a
lot of them for many Downstream problems
actually polom many events are enough
that's it's a useful algorithm design
Paradigm if if you're designing an
algorithm there's only one utility
function yours make predictions that are
good for your utility function and then
best respond to
them but you can do this for more than
one utility function so you can also
think about as a way of Designing
coordination mechanisms single set of
forecasts that incentivize uh many
agents with different utility functions
to best respond to
them um and there's a you know concrete
mechanism design application in contract
theory that I don't have time to tell
you
about um there's a there's a whole other
collection of applications that I
definitely don't have time to tell you
about because they don't relate to
anything I've talked about at all but
are about uncertainty quantification
producing prediction sets in machine
learning and if you've ever heard of
conformal prediction which at this work
sh there's no reason you should have but
it's some general family of techniques
for a
fixing arbitrary machine learning
algorithms with prediction sets which
can be subsets of the labels they're
predicting when you hear the word subset
you should worry oh there's
exponentially many of these and the way
the conformal prediction literature
solves this problem is it sort of makes
a very important choice early on to
project this exponentially large space
onto like a onedimensional laminer
family and it's like a onedimensional
optimization problem you can solve it
but you've really like lost a lot of
information by projecting things down to
one dimension well using these tools you
don't have to do that anymore you don't
have to um reduce things to one
dimension you can directly calibrate the
class probabilities to you know not full
calibration but to the task at hand okay
thank you uh all credit is due to my
co-authors and the paper is on archive
as of yesterday
[Applause]
thank you time for the C break
get